in the novel 1984 George Orwell
described a world where televisions
called telescreens also had cameras in
them to spy on the viewers your computer
or even your mobile phone has all the
hardware to be turned into a spying
device just like a telescreen modern
computers are designed so that the user
of the device has control over the
programs that run on the machine but
sometimes others try to take control of
your computer or phone malicious hackers
have been doing this since well at least
1984 the term for remotely taking over
control of a computer is owning or
owning it here's how to protect yourself
against such an intimate violation of
your privacy
the most common way your computer can
get owned as if you get tricked into
running a program that can happen if you
click on an email attachment that
appears innocent but is actually
malicious malicious software is called
malware it can turn on your computer's
microphones and broadcasted
conversations it can record your screen
watch what you type on your keyboard
copy files and even insert false records
malware is most often used for stealing
passwords and identity theft but it can
be used for political purposes to
activists opposing the government of
Vietnam Bahrain Ethiopia and other
countries have received carefully
crafted fake emails that took over their
computers China and the United States
are also strongly suspected of using
their own custom-made malware against
oops so be very careful opening strange
email attachments one way to deal with
the suspicious attachment to someone you
know is to double check with them in
person by phone video chat or instant
message before you open it you should
also be cautious of clicking on
suspicious web links it's possible to
infect a computer with malware remotely
just by visiting a webpage if a link
prompts you to install software don't
agree and if your web browser or search
engine or nzy that a website might be
malicious hit that back button a less
common way that malware can own your
computer is via USB or a Thunderbolt
connector by plugging in attackers can
copy over a malicious program or
otherwise take control of your machine
the same goes for CDs and DVDs this all
may sound scary but always remember that
when it works correctly your computer is
designed to fend off these malware
attacks as long as we keep building
computers so they are intended to be
controlled by their owners you'll have a
chance to fight back against being home
for more about malware and detecting
remote attacks on your computer check
out the Electronic Frontier Foundation
surveillance self-defense